la situation de la gare de la verrière
soulève un mouvement de contestation peu
commun ils sont quatre maires de
couleurs politiques différentes unis
pour le réaménagement de la station
hesdinoise l'ump ps uni parti communiste
distribuer des tracts côte à côte les
usagers qui signent la pétition semblent
rassurés par cette action commune je
trouve ça très bien parce que peut-être
que je veux dire l'union fait la force
donc peut-être que là il y aura plus de
monde il y aura peut-être plus de on
sera plus écoutée peut-être et ça aura
peut-être plus d'effet c'est une très
bonne chose que les villes tunis on a
besoin de travailler de manière
coordonnée donc c'est que c'est une
bonne chose que les ils travaillent
ensemble sur ce dossier en l'espace de
24 heures la pétition a reçu plus de 950
signature ça prouve que lorsque l'enjeu
en vaut la chandelle les élus sont
capables de se réunir c'est pour ça que
je disais il ya quelques minutes c'est
une action civique et républicaine ce
n'est pas une action politique au sens
habituel c'est pas un coût des partis
différents d'un parti-pris commun celui
d'améliorer les conditions de transport
des usagers de la gare ils sont nombreux
ils viennent de maurepas et viennent de
coignières ils viennent du 1000 5000
viennent de la vallée de chevreuse et
effectivement il se retrouve ici dans
des conditions inacceptables d'accueil
d'accessibilité et quand on rajoute à
cela des lignes extrêmement perturbé
avec du matériel un peu vétuste
franchement c'est pas c'est pas digne de
notre époque avec cette pétition les
élus espèrent notamment voir la ligne c
du rer prolongé jusqu à coignières et la
mise aux normes d'accessibilité de la
verrière avant 2015 il devrait envoyer
une lettre ouverte la semaine prochaine
au président de la sncf guillaume pepy